J'ai peur Connie qu'il y ait un hélicoptère
qui nous attend sur le toit garde tes
yeux sur maman et papa d'accord comment
savons-nous qu'ils arrivent ils arrivent
mr.  sous-secrétaire, votre secrétaire ici
dit que vous étiez son meilleur enquêteur lorsque
vous êtes avec vous, nous vous enverrons
avec l'aide de l'équipe dr.  Faust bog trouver
quoi que ce soit il a besoin de votre large Je le
veux pour que les circonstances parlent
pour lui-même ne peut pas aider vous ne pouvez pas quitter
ma famille jetez un oeil ici mr.
Lane chacune de ces personnes
est ici parce qu'elle sert un but
il n'y a pas de place ici pour une personnalité non essentielle
vous voulez aider votre famille
voyons comment nous arrêtons cela c'est
votre choix mr.  voie